sie sind groß bizarr an farbe und form
ein bisschen unheimlich und unfassbar
faszinierend zumindest für sehr viele
leute herzlich willkommen zur
sternstunde philosophie die uns heute in
die urzeit führt ich möchte herausfinden
warum wir uns für die ausgestorbenen
dinosaurier interessieren
und was sie uns sagen über die frage ob
auch wir nur eine episode sind
ich freue mich dabei jetzt mit einem der
renommiertesten dinosaurier forscher
unserer zeit zu sprechen nämlich mit dem
paläontologen die studie von der
universität edinburgh herzlich
willkommen
danke für die einladung ja wenn wir über
dinosaurier sprechen dann behelfen wir
uns oft mit solchen modellen wir stellen
uns die dinosaurier auf eine bestimmte
art und weise vor
und sie sagen sie oft machen wir uns
falsche bilder zum beispiel hatten viele
dinosaurier offenbar federn spielsachen
wie die auf diesem tisch finden sich in
vielen schulen und kinderzimmern
auch ich hatte als kind viele solche
spielzeuge lustig wenn auch nicht ganz
wirklichkeitsgetreu in den letzten
jahrzehnten sind die zu ganz neuen
erkenntnissen gekommen
wir wissen heute zum beispiel dass
dinosaurier den vögeln viel ähnlicher
sind als den krokodilen oder echsen die
heutigen vögel sind tatsächlich auch aus
den dinosauriern hervorgegangen einige
der hier versammelten dinosaurier wie
die terex hatten offenbar federn oder
sogar flügel
das entspricht nicht dem bild das wir
uns früher von dinosauriern machten
sogar noch in meiner jugend in den
späten 80er und 90er jahren mit den
vielen dinosaurier funden in jüngster
zeit hat sich unser bild rasant und
stark geändert
aber manchmal haben wir lieber wenn die
dinosaurier so bleiben wie sie sind also
zb in jurassic park hat steven spielberg
auch gesagt er wisse schon dass gewisse
dinge nicht stimmen
aber wenn man ihnen federn aufgesetzt
hätte dann hätten sie weniger furcht der
regen aus gesehen deswegen sind die
dinosaurier in jurassic park alle nackt
über jurassic park gab es so einiges zu
sagen ich muss vorausschicken dass ich
ein großer fan von diesem film er ist
etwas vom besten was der paläontologie
je passiert ist weil er in so vielen
kindern und jugendlichen die
begeisterung für dinosaurier geweckt hat
damit wuchs auch das allgemeine
interesse an dinosauriern und es gab
viel mehr mittel und folglich immer mehr
kurse an den universitäten jurassic park
war also eine gute sache das heißt aber
nicht dass die dinosaurier im film
perfekte dinosaurier wären ich möchte
das aber nicht zu sehr kritisieren denn
die dinosaurier dort sind ziemlich gut
zwar haben sie zumindest in den ersten
film tatsächlich keine federn
aber man muss diesen spielberg gut
erhalten dass man das 1993 als der erste
film gedreht wurde schlicht nicht wusste
es war noch kein dinosaurier fossil mit
federn gefunden worden
erst später 1996 97 stieß man in china
auf die ersten funde mit federn
spielberg wusste es nicht besser es gibt
einen ein solches verziehen dass sie
auch gefunden haben nämlich dieses hier
für mich war interessant dass sich die
federn in diesem fossil erst gar nicht
gesehen haben es sind nämlich nicht
diese dinger hier in der mitte das sind
die rippen dieses dinosaurier sondern
außen rum diese chancen
das ist einer meiner lieblings
dinosaurier ich habe ihn vor ein paar
jahren beschrieben und ihm seinen namen
gegeben
er ist ein rad tor ein naher verwandter
des bekannten velociraptor aus jurassic
park
entdeckt wurde das fossil von einem
bauern in china der auf dem feld
arbeiten
man stelle sich das vor du bist am
bestellen deiner felder und plötzlich
stößt worauf dieses wunderschöne fossil
auf diesem schwarz-weiß-foto ist es
nicht einfach zu erkennen
auf einem farbbild aber sehe man flügel
und am ganzen schwanz und körper federn
hier zeigt sich die enge verwandtschaft
zwischen vielen dinosauriern und vögeln
jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt ein bauer
hat das gefunden dieses versehen das
zeigte auch für unglaublich zufällig
diese funde sind wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen wenn sie ins feld gehen wie
wissen sie eigentlich was überhaupt zu
graben beginnen sollen weil das hier
einfach alles mit erde bedeckt
im gelände einer dinosaurier fossilien
zu suchen ist nur ein teil meiner arbeit
ich habe eine einstellung an der
universität edinburgh in schottland und
unterrichtet dort viele kurse und
betreuer ein mast aberkannt wenn wir
jetzt also zuhört und ein master in
paläontologie machen möchte darf uns
gerne kontaktieren
zu meinem job gehört es aber eben auch
aktiv im gelände zu suchen diese
forschungs exkursionen wollen
vorbereitet sein
wir müssen einschätzen wo es dinosaurier
fossilien geben kann
man kann nicht einfach in der mitte von
zürich zu graben beginnen und hoffen
dort auf ein fossil zu stoßen
vielmehr muss man bestimmte
gesteinsschichten ausfindig machen das
gestein muss sich zu der zeit gebildet
haben als es dinosaurier gab es muss
sich auf land flüssen oder seen an den
orten gebildet haben wo dinosaurier
lebten und es muss auf der erdoberfläche
sichtbar sein
wir finden diese orte über eine
vertiefte studie der jeweiligen geologie
wenn wir einen solchen ort ausfindig
gemacht haben fahren wir hin und
erkunden das gelände
wir setzen dabei keine speziellen geräte
wie radar oder so nein nein wir schauen
uns einfach um das bedingt aber dass wir
vorher unsere hausaufgaben gemacht haben
so erklären sich aber auch die vielen
zufälligen kunde durch einen bauern bei
der feldarbeit wien 10 uhr an long oder
einen arbeiter beim aushub für ein haus
auch wanderer oder sogar kinder finden
manchmal dinosaurier
das ist bemerkenswert in anderen
wissenschaftsgebieten läuft es ziemlich
anders einen amateur nuklearphysiker
kann man sich schwer vorstellen einen
amateur paläontologen aber schon um
fossilien zu finden braucht es keinen
doktorat das heißt ich würde das auch
erkennen also ich meine wenn ich jetzt
so etwas finden würde ja aber einen
dinosaurier knochen da will ich doch
wahrscheinlich nicht einfach denke sein
und stein
vielleicht ich kriege jede woche e mails
von leuten gerade aus schottland sie
glauben einen dinosaurier knochen einen
fußabdruck oder gar ein dinosaurier
entdeckt haben
oft muss ich sie dann enttäuschen weil
es sich schlicht um ein stein mit der so
ähnlich aussieht
manchmal aber finden leute tatsächlich
sehr interessante dinge vor allem neue
fußabdrücke von denen sie mir dann ein
bild schicken
es gibt solche glücksfälle normalerweise
braucht es aber schon einige erfahrung
solche dinge zu erkennen
wir studieren ja auch so lange an der
universität damit wir alle dinosaurier
knochen kennen und anhand der geologie
einschätzen können welche art in frage
kommen darüber sprechen was wir uns für
bilder machen von den dinosauriern gibt
es auch manchmal den vorwurf es gebe es
bei sie einen dinosaurier rassismus
nämlich dass in all den filmen immer die
gleichen dinosaurier auftauchen die
typischerweise in nordamerika gefunden
worden sind und alle die neuen arten die
man in afrika entdeckt oder in indien
oder in china wie kommen überhaupt nicht
vor als filmstars leben sie das
bestätigen
interessanterweise erleben wir gerade
jetzt die aufregendste zeit in der
forschungsgeschichte der paläontologe
noch nie hat man so viele dinosaurier
gefunden
es klingt unglaublich ich gebe ihn aber
mein wort das im durchschnitt jede woche
eine neue dinosaurier art entdeckt wird
jedes jahr also ungefähr 50 neue arten
dazu kommen wichtig nicht ein neues
fossil ein neuer knochen oder neue
skelett sondern eine neue dinosaurier
spezies die meisten dieser funde werden
in china brasilien oder argentinien
gemacht in diesen riesigen aufstrebenden
ländern wo eine neue generation junger
wissenschaftler an vielen neuen
universitäten ausgebildet wird
im neunzehnten und teilweise auch im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert war die
paläontologie einer kleinen elitären
gruppe an den großen universitäten in
den usa kanada und dem vereinigten
königreich oder deutschland vergeben sie
entdeckten viele der heute bekanntesten
dinosaurier rex brontosaurus stegosaurus
die terra tops die alle aus nordamerika
und europa stark ich bin mir aber sicher
dass in 20 bis 30 jahren all die neuen
dinosaurier aus china argentinien oder
brasilien genau so bekannt sein werden
wie der terex heute ist das eigentlich
wenn ich so ein fossil finde gehört mir
das dann
es ist schwer zu erklären wie es ist ein
fossil zu finden
liebe lässt sich auch nicht so einfach
beschreiben
nicht begeistert bei der entdeckung von
fossilien das wissen der erster mensch
zu sein der dieses objekt je gesehen hat
wenn wir eine neue art finden sind wir
die allerersten die verstehen dass
dieses tier vor millionen von jahren
gelebt hat ist das ist sehr schön
jedes fossil ist wichtig weil es
aufschlüsse darüber gibt was vor
dutzenden oder gar hunderten von
millionen jahren geschah bevor es
überhaupt menschen gab fossilien zu
suchen und zu finden ist mehr als eine
spurensuche
weil jedes fossil ein kleines bindeglied
zu lange verschwundenen welten ist
wollte vorher noch wissen dem die
fossilien eigentlich gehören die
gefunden werden
also ist dieser pharma zum beispiel
jetzt vermögen weil er dieses großartige
tier entdeckt hat das hängt vom
jeweiligen land ab die gesetze
unterscheiden sie strahlen die gesetze
in china zum beispiel sind sehr strikt
fossilien die dort gefunden werden
dürfen das land nicht verlassen
wer in den usa etwas auf seinem eigenen
land findet kann damit tun was er will
es ist also sehr unterschiedlich als
wissenschaftler unter stehen wir aber
einen ethik kodex
wir können keine fossilien sammeln
behalten oder verkaufen
unsere funde gehen an museen wo sie
wissenschaftlern zur verfügung stehen
und wo sie andere wissenschaftler
untersuchen können um unsere arbeit
überprüfen oder zu widerlegen
jetzt haben sie vorher eine art
werbespot für die paläontologie
abgegeben wie wichtig diese disziplin
ist alle unsere wurzeln verstehen das
sind ja nicht die wurzeln der menschen
aber die evolutionsgeschichte immer
weiter aufdröseln trotzdem ist es so
dass zum beispiel in deutschland die
professorin für paläontologie immer
weniger
werden die disziplinen gilt als auch
ideen fach sie ist unter beschuss man
fragt sich wozu eigentlich
was antworten sie wieso brauchen wir
paläontologen mal abgesehen davon dass
es für sie viel spaß bedeutet es macht
tatsächlich spaß es ist ein großartiger
job weil er mit abenteuer und romantik
verbunden ist
alle lieben dinosaurier und fossilien
deshalb haben wir die möglichkeit die
menschen mit unserer arbeit anzusprechen
weil es zudem ist das fach ähnlich
wichtig wie die geschichtswissenschaft
um die veränderungen der menschen und
ihre entscheidungen im laufe der zeit
verstehen und daraus lehren ziehen zu
können braucht es historiker bei den
fossilien ist es ähnlich
wir müssen verstehen wie die erde sich
im laufe der zeit verändert hat
wir müssen wissen die evolution und
klimawandel funktionieren wie sich der
klimawandel und die umwelt veränderung
konkret auch organismen pflanzen tiere
und ökosysteme ausgewählt haben wir
brauchen diese information weil sich
unsere welt und unser klima so rasant
verändern wenn wir etwas dagegen tun
wollen müssen wir diese veränderung über
die zeit verstehen diese informationen
erhalten wir nur über fossilien
deshalb ist die paläontologie so richtig
es müssen also mittel bereitgestellt
werden damit die paläontologie auch
weiterhin an universitäten und museen
gefördert werden kann
über den zusammenhang zwischen evolution
paläontologie und klimawissenschaften
sprechen wir nachher gleich noch für die
gerne noch einmal auch bei der
faszination die die tiere bleiben
dieses dino fieber ist das eigentlich
weltumspannend sie haben der
ausgrabungen gemacht in litauen in
rumänen
in china sind alle menschen
gleichermaßen fasziniert oder gibt es
auch keine ahnung länder wo sie denken
das interessiert keinen
hier ist noch kein land begegnet indem
man diese tiere nicht mag
ich kann mich täuschen aber mir scheint
dass die menschen überall in der welt
von dinosauriern fasziniert sind vor
allem kinder lieben die sache
überall in den schulen und kinderzimmern
spielen kinder mit solchen spielzeug
dinosauriern und stellen sich vor wie
die welt früher war diese tiere üben
eine faszination aus vielleicht stimmen
bei diesem exemplar nicht alle details
so ist es seine arme sind ein bisschen
zu lang und er hat auch zu viele finger
aber darum geht es ja nicht sondern
darum dass er zwar aussieht wie ein
drache oder ein monster aber viel
interessanter ist als alle drachen
einhörner und seeschlangen aus unseren
mythen oder legenden
denn er war real
er hat tatsächlich einmal gelebt und das
macht ihn für uns so fasziniert und ich
denke diese faszination wird anhalten
für mich als wissenschaftler ist das
großartig denn so erhalte ich die
aufmerksamkeit und das interesse der
menschen für die erdgeschichte und ihre
veränderungen etwas was nicht fasziniert
ist die schiere größe dieser tiere also
wenn man sich das mal vorstellen dass
ein solches tier unter umständen 100
tonnen schwer sein konnte unter
umständen 1,8 millionen mal schwerer als
ich wenn man sie einfach mal vorstellt
es ist unfassbar groß und schwer
1500 kilogramm kot pro tag
also eine unfassbare menge wir sehen
hier auch eine grafik um sie sehen eine
frau links am bildrand im verhältnis zu
diesen dinosauriern ist es nicht also
ich würde sagen wahrscheinlich ein teil
der faszination hängt auch mit der größe
zusammen oder ich bin absolut
einverstanden
masse die epische größe der dinosaurier
macht sie so interessant aber wie man in
der grafik sieht waren nicht alle
dinosaurier riesig der dinosaurier neben
der frau ist etwa so groß wie ein hund
und es gab auch noch kleinere die so
gross waren die tauben hat aber die
größten war riesig bei dieser
dinosaurier art auch hier stimmt die
darstellung des ganz nun die zähne
stimmen nicht erscheint gerade etwas
anzugreifen
die rote farbe legt nahe dass ein
blutiges stück fleisch im maul hat aber
diese dinosaurier bahn pflanzenfresser
und sehr sanftmütig der stimmt schon
eher
schauen wir uns also diesen jahren wir
nennen diese dinosaurier sauropoden zu
ihm gehören die gattungen brontosaurus
brachiosaurus diplodocus sie sind die
größten tiere die in der gesamten
erdgeschichte von 4 5 milliarden jahren
geht zur land gelegt habe die größten
darunter sind größer als eine boeing 737
das flugzeug mit dem ich gestern hier
nach zürich geflogen bin war also
kleiner als diese dinosaurier
man muss sich das vorstellen
diese tiere schlüpfen aus einem ei das
nicht größer war als dieses glas und
fraßen dann so viel dass sie größer
wurden als ein flugzeug das ist
unglaublich
menschen oder lebten die so lange dass
die so gross werden konnten eine sehr
gute frage
vor ein paar jahrzehnten glaubte die
wissenschaft dass diese dinosaurier wie
ein krokodil jahr für jahr ein größe
zulegten und dann mit 100 oder gar 200
jahren riesig waren
wir wissen heute dass das nicht stimmt
tatsächlich wuchsen viele dieser
dinosaurier etwa so schnell wie wir oder
sogar noch schneller
diese flugzeug großen dinosaurier wurden
lediglich 40 bis 50 jahre alt das wissen
wir aus den wachstums ringen im inneren
ihrer knochen anhand derer man das alter
ermitteln kann wie mit den jahresringen
eines baumstamms man stelle sich also
ein tier vor das aus einem so kleinen
flugzeug groß wird in lediglich 30 bis
40 jahren
es wuchs also sehr schnell ja es war es
nur pflanzen aber wahrscheinlich 200
kilogramm jeden tag es tat also nichts
anderes als fressen fressen fressen
aber warum weiß man etwas darüber warum
die so sehr in die höhe schossen da so
groß wurden
ich wünschte ich hätte eine klare
antwort darauf ich glaube nicht dass
eine einzelne genetische mutation oder
eine einzelne veränderung in der umwelt
es ihnen erlaubte so groß zu werden
ich denke ein zusammenspiel von
bestimmten eigenschaften ihrer körper
und ihre biologie erlaubte es ihnen in
einer langsamen entwicklung so groß zu
werden
mit ihrem langen hals konnten sie auch
die höchsten blätter im baum erreichen
die außer reichweite der anderen
dinosaurier war
hat man also mehr als genug zu fressen
ihre lungen unterschieden sich
grundsätzen von unserem
sie waren sehr effizient und konnten
mehr sauerstoff aufnehmen weiterungen
die man sich wie ballone oder
plastiksäcke vorstellen kann streckten
sich von den lungen in den ganzen körper
aus und fühlt in den körper wie eine
klimaanlage
weil diese luftsäcke innerhalb der
knochen verliefen reduzierte sich ihr
körpergewicht ähnlich einem modernen
wolkenkratzer war dass dinosaurier
skelett trotz seiner größe und
stabilität sehr leicht
das sind einige der eigenschaften die
sich langsam über millionen von jahren
entwickelten und schließlich zusammen
kamen und die dinosaurier größer werden
ließen als alles andere
faszinierend wenn ich ihnen zuhöre zu
merken es ist eine kombination zwischen
dinge finden theorien aufstellen sich
wieder annähern
man hat man vielleicht eine theorie und
irgendwann hier zitiert weil man etwas
neues heraus findet mir fällt in diesem
zusammenhang das riesenfaultier maggie 1
dieses riesenfaultier das ist ein
prähistorisches tier dass stand bis vor
noch nicht allzu langer zeit im
zoologischen museum in zürich und war
der liebling aller kinder und aus man
dieses tier restaurieren musste weil die
kinder sich damit klebrigen schokolade
händchen daran geklammert hatten das
fell war verfilzt hat man gesagt wir
betrachten die neueren studien und es
war völlig klar dieses tier hat sony
ausgesehen das hatte kein fällen
das hatte auch nicht ein niedliches
gesicht sondern wahrscheinlich so aus
und so hätte es aber keiner gemacht das
heißt man frau zitiert dann theorien
ideen wie etwas aus gesehen habt gibt es
etwas wovon sich selbst jetzt schon im
laufe ihrer karriere irgendwann
enttäuscht einsehen mussten dass haben
gestehen haben jetzt total geehrt sie
haben völlig recht dass wir unser wissen
über dinosaurier ständig revidieren und
dank neuer funde oft feststellen dass
frühere annahmen nicht ganz stimmte
jeder entdeckung eines fossils lehrt uns
etwas neues in der wissenschaft generell
lernen chemiker biologen oder physiker
ständig neues testen ihre theorien und
entwickeln bessere erklärungen im licht
neuerer evidenz das zeigt auch ihr
beispiel ich verstehe dass dieses große
büschel trier sehr beliebt war heute
aber wissen wir dass es wohl eher so
ausgesehen hat das paradebeispiel dafür
bei den dinosauriern ist die geschichte
mit den federn
in umkehrung zu diesem todd elik in
säugetier von dem mann fälschlicherweise
annahm es wäre groß niedlich und tätig
gewesen
dinosaurier sah man wie diesen
triceratops am ganzen körper beschreibt
wie eine exe oder ein krokodil aber
heute wissen wir dass viele von ihnen
federn hatten vielleicht da sind wir
nicht sicher
die triceratops funde stammen aus
nordamerika wo sich die fossilien und
flüssen bildeten in denen die tiere
umkamen
in solchen schichten bleiben knochen und
zähne erhalten die federn aber zersetzen
sich in china aber beim 10 yuan long und
anderen fossilien mit federn wurden die
dinosaurier unterlag
massengrab genau wie menschen nach einem
vulkanausbruch im schlaf beim zubereiten
des frühstücks oder auf dem spaziergang
mit dem hund erstarrten sind auch die
dinosaurier in china mit hohem
detaillierungsgrad erhalten deshalb
wissen wir dass auch einzelne vorfahren
des triceratops gefiedert waren
möglicherweise hatten also auch die
kritik ob selbst so etwas wie federn
nicht dass sie fliegen konnten
es wäre lächerlich dass bei so einem
thema anzunehmen aber es hat wohl an
verschiedenen körperstellen einfache h
ähnliche federn gehabt wir sehen also es
gibt ganz viele theorien über die
dinosaurier die man weiter erforschen
wird uns irgendwann findet man wieder
neue sachen heraus etwas ist aber klar
die dinosaurier in dieser art und weise
gibt es nicht mehr die sind ausgestorben
vor 66 millionen jahren und zwar gibt es
die sogenannte impact theorie die besagt
dass ein meteorit oder asteoriden in den
golf von mexiko geknallt ist vor 66
millionen jahren
es gibt eine bbc dokumentation die
versucht dieses ereignis noch einmal
darzustellen wir schauen uns das kurz
anbieten
vor 66 millionen jahren schlug ein
meteorit mit einem durchmesser von rund
zehn kilometern größe bei der yucatan
halbinsel im golf von mexiko auf die
erde ein
so entstand der 180 km große chicxulub
krater feuerwehr riesige erdbeben
tsunamis gigantische staub fällen
erschütterten infolge des einschlags den
gesamten planeten und verbreiteten sich
um die welt der meteoriteneinschlag dies
wahrscheinlich auch den riesigen decken
vulkan in indien explodieren dies
schleuderte nochmals zwei millionen
kubikmeter basalt in die atmosphäre
die totale apokalypse das ende der
dinosaurier
sie lachen nun es ist ihr auch hoch
dramatisch wie in einem viertel sehe man
das in einem blockbuster würde man sagen
das ist durchgeknallt und übertrieben
typisch hollywood
aber das hat sich tatsächlich so
ereignet
ich habe in diesem dokumentarfilm
mitgearbeitet das die bbc dort
beschreibt ist realität
wir wissen das weil der asteroid viele
hinweise im gestein hinterließ einen
krater von über 150 kilometern in mexiko
bezeugt den einschlag des asteroiden
wir wissen dass dieser anschlag globale
auswirkungen hatte weil sich in den
gesteinsschichten dieses alters überall
in der welt stoffe finden die der
asteroid aufgewirbelt hatte die
herabregnen glaskugeln und verkohlten
holzstücke aus den feuersbrünsten
verstreuten sich über die ganze welt
dieser asteroid war der wohl größte der
in den letzten 500 millionen jahren auf
die erde breite da war also viel pech
dabei
dieser asteroid veränderte die ganze
welt unmittelbar von einem tag auf den
anderen
vorher waren die dinosaurier ganz oben
in der nahrungskette
am nächsten tag litten sie massiv ein
buch
dass die geschichte noch einmal der
dinosaurier erzählt und in den usa und
in großbritannien zu einem bestseller
avanciert ist und in diesem buch
beschreiben sie das so plastisch dass
man richtig mit leidet mit dieser
dinosaurier familie die betroffen ist
wobei sie natürlich nicht diese familie
die sie beschreiben ist nicht unterhalb
des meteoriten sofort ausgelöst sondern
es kommen nach und nach immer mehr
wellen sozusagen die die die die erde
bebt es gibt die vulkane es gibt tsunami
ist die atmosphäre verdunkelt sich und
so weiter man denkt dazwischen
eigentlich hätten sie auch roman autor
werden können
so war es für die meisten in einem
umkreis von 1000 bis 1500 kilometern
kamen die dinosaurier wohl alle sofort
um all die anderen dinosaurier auf der
ganzen erde überlebten wohl etwas länger
litten aber unter den erdbeben den
tsunami und dem feuer
später dann auch dem schmutz und staub
in der atmosphäre welche die sonne
verdunkelt
dieser nukleare winter dauerte mehrere
jahre aus lichtmangel sterben die
pflanzen und die nahrungsketten brachen
zusammen
es folgte eine globale erwärmung über
die nächsten paar tausend jahre
wir wissen dass aufgrund von alldem
sämtliche dinosaurier innerhalb von
10.000 jahren verschwunden waren mit
ausnahme einiger weniger vogelarten die
auf den dinosauriern hervorgegangen sind
das geschah alles sehr schnell und das
ist interessant es geschah sehr schnell
10.000 jahre für einen politologen ist
das schnell für mich ist natürlich
unglaublich lang auch wenn die die
menschheitsgeschichte anschauen
vielleicht kann hier mal einen
zeitstrahl sehen wie die dinosaurier
sich entwickelt haben also wir sehen vor
235 millionen jahren ungefähr haben die
begonnen sich zu entwickeln 66 millionen
jahre kam dann dieses dieser einschlag
und wir sehen auf der letzten
meine der geschichte des planeten sieht
man da noch den menschen kurz darauf
marschieren
also das heißt die zeiträume sind enorm
wie lange die dinosaurier gelebt haben
das ist enorm
glauben sie eigentlich der mensch könnte
auch so ein dauerbrenner werden
sie hatten ja harar in dieser sendung
nicht sein
ich bin unendlich dazugekommen und
sapiens zu lesen und ich liebe das buch
es erzählt die komplette geschichte der
menschheit und ist großartig aber diese
geschichte umspannt lediglich ein paar
zehntausend jahre die geschichte unserer
spezies homo sapiens umfasst insgesamt
200.000 jahre
das ist nichts im vergleich zu den
dinosaurier wir sehen auf dieser grafik
dass sich die ersten dinosaurier vor 230
bis 240 millionen jahren entwickelten
und bis vor 66 millionen jahren
fortbestanden und als folge sogar bis
heute die dinosaurier beherrschten die
welt also über 150 millionen jahre lang
mehr als 500 mal so lange wie es uns
überhaupt
wir haben also einen langen weg vor uns
wie die dinosaurier im mesozoikum stehen
wir heute als herrscher der welt an der
spitze der nahrungskette
aber angesichts der rasanten
veränderungen in unserer welt bezweifle
ich dass wir auch nur annähernd in die
nähe der herrschaft dauer der
dinosaurier kommen wenn wir unser
verhalten der umwelt gegenüber nicht
ändern und so ist es ja tatsächlich dass
ganz viele leute jetzt sagen wir sind am
abgrund der menschheit wir sind kurz
davor ist ganz zu verlassen und dann
werden wir nur diese mini episode sein
für die sich eigentlich gar niemanden
interessiert würden sie sagen der mensch
ist schlecht für den planeten
der mensch ist eine von vielen
milliarden spezies
die sich im laufe der zeit entwickelt
haben einige spezies haben den planeten
mehr zugesetzt als andere und wir
gehören dazu
das problem ist dass die auswirkungen
unseres tuns so schlagartig sichtbar
werden neu ist die geschwindigkeit in
der erdgeschichte hat es natürlich auch
schon zeiten globaler erwärmung gegeben
die temperaturen ändern sich immer auch
die meeresspiegel sind in der geschichte
der erde schon angestiegen
die meeresspiegel ändern sich immer aber
heute geschieht das viel schneller als
zuvor
das beste beispiel dafür ist das große
massensterben vor den dinosauriern
da spielte sich vor etwa 250 millionen
jahren
damals starben circa 95 prozent aller
spezies aus eine spezies hat er also
damals eine 5 prozentige
überlebenschance
dieses sterben ging einzig auf die
globale erwärmung zu rücken die
damaligen organismen verbrannten
natürlich keine fossilen brennstoffe
aber da wo heute russland ist spuckten
lesen vulkane ein paar millionen jahre
lang lava aber auch co2 methan und
andere treibhausgase aus sie gelangten
in die atmosphäre und verbreiteten sich
über die ganze erde was zu einer
globalen erwärmung führte die so schlimm
war dass 95 prozent aller spezies auch
starten dieses massensterben dauerte ein
paar millionen jahre unsere globale
erwärmung vollzieht sich innert
jahrzehnten oder jahrhunderten was wir
den planeten antun ist einzigartig in
der erdgeschichte hinsichtlich der
geschwindigkeit der veränderung
das ist das wirkliche problem was immer
geschieht die erde wird es überleben
aber die erde die nach dieser episode
entsteht ist vielleicht eine ganz andere
wir menschen haben und biologisch und
zivilisatorisch so entwickelt dass wir
auf diesem planeten leben kann
mit den heute bestehenden temperaturen
und meeresspiegel
unser ganzes system beruht größtenteils
darauf man denke an die landwirtschaft
mehr bange weil wir nicht wissen wie
sich alles genau verändert genau das
haben jetzt mehrere male betont dass die
geschwindigkeit mit der diese
veränderung vor sich geht eine ganz
andere ist weil ihr vor immer in diesen
unglaublichen zeithorizonten gesprochen
haben aber trotzdem ist es so wie sich
jetzt auch betont haben sie haben das
vierte massensterben erwähnt das war das
vierte in der geschichte der der des
planeten
es gab das fünfte massensterben mit dem
aussterben der dinosaurier und nun gibt
es viele die sagen wir stehen kurz davor
ein sechstes massensterben zu erleben zb
eberhard brandes der chef vom wwf
deutschland
der sagt wir sind kurz davor so viel
biodiversität zu vernichten wie es
eigentlich seit der zeit der dinosaurier
nicht mehr der fall war
jetzt sagen sie die geschwindigkeit ist
der unterschied macht es für sie auch
ein unterschied dass wir menschen das
verursachen oder würden sie sagen na ja
auch der mensch mit seinen zielen und
zwecken ist ja teil der erde das ist
auch irgendwie natur
ja wir sind teil der erde
wir müssen aufhören damit und also
besonders anzusehen dass die regeln der
evolution nicht auf uns zu treffen
zwar verändern wir die erde sehr schnell
wir haben uns aber auch mit der erde
entwickelt bereits früher in der
erdgeschichte haben sich bestimmte
spezies entwickelt die den planeten
dramatisch verändert haben
die ersten lebensformen waren winzige
bakterien die man nur unter dem
mikroskop hätte sehen können
später entwickelten sich andere formen
von bakterien die sauerstoff
produzierten als teil ihrer atmung ihrer
physiologie dieser sauerstoff hat sich
in der atmosphäre verteilt
und atmosphäre und erde komplett
verrückt vor diesen bakterien gab es
sehr wenig sauerstoff auf der erde
diese episode löschte wahrscheinlich
viel los es gab auch andere tiere und
organismen die vor uns die erde
beeinflusst haben wir aber tun das mit
einer horrenden geschwindigkeit
das ist der größte unterschied deshalb
komme ich immer wieder auf die
geschwindigkeit zurück wir sprechen über
etwas was seit 150 jahren geschieht die
erde ist 4,5 milliarden jahre alt die
geschwindigkeit ist also das eine zum
anderen wussten diese sauerstoff
produzierenden bakterien ja nicht was
sie damit anrichten
sie hatten nicht die fähigkeit darüber
nachzudenken pläne für eine verminderung
oder verbesserung zu schmieden
wie aber können dass wir haben diese
gewaltigen hirne und bewusstsein
entwickelt und wissen um die folgen
unseres tuns wir wissen dass co2 ein
treibhausgas ist wir wissen dass
treibhausgase die erdatmosphäre erwärmen
und gibt eine verantwortung
ich denke ja absolut
unser wissen darum erlaubt uns keine
ausrede
natürlich gibt es immer wieder leute die
das aus politischen gründen abstreiten
aber die wissenschaftliche grundlage ist
eindeutig wenn man kohle und
kohlenwasserstoffe verbrennt entstehen
treibhausgase die in die atmosphäre
gelangen in die erde erhitzen
diese veränderungen können wir in
echtzeit beobachten und messen
alleine dadurch unterscheiden wir uns
von allem was die evolution bisher
hervorgebracht hat
auch von den dinosauriern dinosaurier
sterben nicht weg der globalen erwärmung
aus sondern wegen eines asteroiden aber
sie wussten nichts über asteroiden und
sie hätten das geschehen auch nicht
aufhalten können wir aber können dass
ich kann nur hoffen dass wir das in
zukunft besser machen
ich bin kein politiker alles ist mir
bewusst dass es sich um ein vertracktes
problem handelt aber wir müssen uns
wenigstens gewahr werden dass das
zeitfenster für veränderungen nur sehr
eng ist ansonsten könnten wir so enden
wie die dinosaurier
die sichtweise eines paläontologen auf
den klimawandel finde ich auch deswegen
so interessant weil man ja auch sich
vorstellen könnte dass sie sagen naja
die dinosaurier die haben ihre chance
erhalten weil es das vierte
massensterben gab sie sind sozusagen
nachdem ihr wüste war auf diesem
planeten sind die in diesem moment
konnten die sich entwickeln und
vielleicht können wir uns vorstellen
auch wenn der mensch mal vorbei ist wann
kommt etwas neues ist dieser blickwinkel
des paläontologen auch zulässig wenn sie
sagen nein darüber sollten wir gar nicht
sprechen sonst hören die leute auf
klimaschutz zu betreiben
superior als paläontologe weiß ich das
massensterben per se schlecht ist oder
schlimm sind massensterben kommen vor
sie schaffen manchmal raum für neues
spezies die schon lange daran sterben
aus neue spezies bekommen dadurch eine
gelegenheit sich zu entwickeln
die welt verändert sich all das befeuert
die evolution die heutige diversität an
leben wurde durch früheres aussterbe und
die möglichkeit der entwicklung neuen
lebens danach geformt die durch vulkane
verursachte erderwärmung vor 250
millionen jahren war nicht schlecht böse
oder falsch so funktioniert die erde
halten für die heutigen veränderungen
aber tragen wir die verantwortung
ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch über
tausend sachen sprechen aber ganz kurz
vielleicht noch einmal zurück zu dieser
impact theorie ich sitze hier ja auch
als journalistin und uns die
verschiedenen theorien im blick haben
und es ist ja nicht so dass es nicht
einen streit darüber geben was genau zu
diesem aussterben geführt hat es gibt
neben der impact theorie die funk an
ismus theorie und da gibt es eine
schweizerin die sehr prominent ist gerta
keller die eben sagt nein nein das war
nicht so sondern die lehrt an der
universität princeton und die sagt im
bäcker- und trat in indien da haben
diesen korn begonnen vor sich hin zu
spielen das hat schon zu einer
veränderung der atmosphäre geführt und
natürlich gab es diesen einschlag des
meteoriten aber letztendlich ist die
abfolge sozusagen auch leicht anders
gewesen
ich will gar nicht mit ihnen darüber
streiten welche theorie stimmt weil ich
habe noch nichts dazu beizutragen
mich interessiert etwas anderes nämlich
die tatsache dass 2010 ganz viele
wissenschaftler von der ganzen welt in
seien sind der großen zeitschrift an
einer haupt manifest veröffentlicht und
gesagt haben der streit ist beigelegt
wir sind hier für die impact theorie
können wissenschaftler wie
mehrheitsvotum einen solchen streit
aufbrechen
kenny saerbeck wird bei einem der als
faszinierenden thema wie dem aussterben
der dinosaurier zu den so viel geforscht
wurde über die jahre gibt es
notwendigerweise unterschiedliche
theorien die miteinander im wettstreit
liegen man wird sich wohl nie mit den
gefundenen antworten zufrieden
sagen sie doch professor keller in die
sendung eines würde mir spaß machen mit
ihr zur frage asteroid versus vulkane
ein streitgespräch zu führen es gab in
der tat gleichzeitig große
vulkanausbrüche der zum aussterben
beigetragen haben könnte aber es gibt
zwei hauptgründe weshalb ich ein starker
verfechter der asteroid theorie bin
sehen wir keine großen veränderungen in
der diversität und der entwicklung der
dinosaurier vor dem asteroid einschlag
auch während des vulkanismus lebten
dinosaurier überall in der welt in
großer zahl und diversität große kleine
fleisch pflanzenfresser die vulkane
haben ihnen also offenbar nicht gross
geschafft
zweitens fanden sich nach dem asteroiden
einschlag nirgendwo mehr in der welt
dinosaurier fossilien nicht ein knochen
nicht ein zahn nichts natürlich mit
ausnahme der vögel die überlebten ihre
vernichtung geht deshalb klar auf den
asteroiden zurück über eine mögliche
rolle der vulkane können wir aber
durchaus debattieren gut möglich dass
die ökosysteme der dinosaurier dadurch
über gebühr belastet wird geschwächt
wurden
diese these lässt sich aber nur schwer
prüfen weil wir trotz der zahlreichen
fossilienfunde keine aussagen darüber
machen können was jahr für jahr
oder jahrhundert für jahrhundert genau
geschah im besten fall lassen sich
veränderungen lediglich in der
größenordnung von tausend oder
zehntausend jahren feststellen
aber das aussterben der dinosaurier ist
noch lange nicht vollständig erforscht
die wissenschaft ist keine
mehrheitsübernahme parlamentarische
demokratie in der wissenschaft erstellt
man ständig fragen sammelt und bewertet
neue evidenz
ich finde den artikel gut
er fasst die bestehende forschung
zusammen und es wird klar dass sie für
die asteroid theorie spricht damit bin
ich einverstanden
als staatsanwalt in gericht würde ich
das bedeutet aber nicht dass das thema
damit abgehandelt ist und keine weiteren
studien dazu veröffentlicht werden oder
uns neue befunde nicht umdenken lassen
als wissenschaftler müssen wir
unvoreingenommen bleiben der asteroid
wurde erst 1980 entdeckt vor 35 oder 40
jahren wäre die mehrheitsmeinung eine
ganz andere gewesen
im lichte der neuen forschung ist diese
theorie aber nicht mehr haltbar
sie befassen sich mit dingen die so
lange her sind nun trotzdem ist diese
wissenschaft so dynamisch das ist
wirklich faszinierend etwas was auch
ganz viele leute interessiert mich auch
ist ob diese dinosaurier je zurückkehren
werden
das ist ja die geschichte die ganz viele
hollywood filme erzählen viele science
fiction filme erzählen und wenn wir an
jurassic park denken da geht es da
natürlich 1990 um den roman damals von
michael klitschko der die vorlage
geschrieben hat jurassic park als roman
vorlage für den film und in diesem film
ist es tatsächlich so dass die
dinosaurier zurückkehren
nun gibt es einen wissenschaftlichen
berater dieses filmstar ist auch
paläontologe und das ist ja cool und
jack warner überlegte ich tatsächlich
nicht wie wir jetzt wie im film
irgendwie eine dna kreieren können aber
wie wir das huhn so verändern können
dass daraus ein
jetzt hören wir ganz kurz zu
[Musik]
ein ticket service oder ein huhn rosa
muss ist das eine gute idee
nun das ist eine sehr interessante und
für mich auch philosophische frage ich
möchte vorausschicken dass jack ein sehr
bedeutender dinosaurier paläontologe und
eine große inspiration für viele von
euch sein buch hat nicht in den 80er
jahren auf die dinosaurier gebracht was
er im vortrag bespricht evolutionäre
entwicklungsbiologie und grundsätzlich
machbar
man kann die gene heutiger tiere
manipulieren und so bestimmte strukturen
wie bei den vorfahren oft noch vorhanden
waren dann aber im laufe der zeit
genetisch abgeschaltet wurden zum
wachsen bringen
es stellt sich aber die frage ob wir das
auch tun sollten
in kloten von dinosauriern also wie in
jurassic park mit dinosaurier dna einen
dinosaurier aus fossilem zu klonen und
so den terex touristen bringen wird
nicht geschehen weil sich sehr schnell
zersetzt überlebt sie nicht in fossilien
es tut mir leid das sagen zu müssen aber
das ist nicht möglich
park das ist ja so dass es um mücken
geht die dinosaurier gestochen haben das
blut raus gezogen haben und die sind
konserviert in bernstein so erzählt es
der roman und der film und aus diesen
mücken wird dann die dna entnommen also
das ist nicht funktionsfähig angeht
nicht passieren
unmöglich unvoreingenommener
wissenschaftler sollte man grundsätzlich
nie sagen dass etwas unmöglich ist aber
dna zersetzt sich selbst in menschen
sehr schnell wenn kriminologen jahre
zurückliegende mordfälle lösen wollen
stehen auch sie vor diesem problem
niemand hat auch nur einen kleinsten
teil dinosaurier dna gefunden
und glauben sie mir jeder möchte dass
jeder paläontologe weiß welcher roaming
sicher ist menne er als erster
dinosaurier dna findet aber niemand hat
auch nur ein einziges basenpaare
gefunden und ein genug hat er viele
tausend basenpaaren
es spricht also alles dagegen dass sich
dna so lange erhalten lässt und selbst
wenn jemand irgendwie irgendwo
dinosaurier dna findet dann nicht
widerlegt in dem was ich hier im
fernsehen sagen wäre es sehr schwierig
einen dinosaurier zu klonen weil man
dafür ja eine mutter braucht die das ei
liegt ein mammut zu klonen ist das eine
da kann man vielleicht eine elefantenkuh
einsetzen was aber würde man als mutter
für einen terex benutzen selbst wenn man
auch dieses problem lösen könnte würde
ich argumentieren dass wir das rein
philosophisch nicht machen sollten damit
würde dir gott spielen dinosaurier wie
der terex lebten vor sehr langer zeit
sie hatten ihre zeit in der sie gedient
und sie hatten eine tolle zeit
weil sie lange ganz oben standen in der
nacht dann aber starben sie aus wegen
des asteroiden nicht wegen uns wir sind
also für ihr aussterben nicht
verantwortlich
wenn wir sie in die heutige welt zurück
brächten während sich ihr fremd ein
t-rex würde nicht wissen wie er
überleben könnte in dieser welt in der
alles anders ist der atmosphäre die
pflanzen seine beutetiere selbst die
bakterien in seinem darm wären andere er
wäre wie ein mensch der auf dem planeten
venus zu überleben versucht das wäre
sehr grausam so viel zum klonen der
holos den sie angesprochen haben ist
eine andere geschichte
hier nimmt man einen modernen vogel und
manipuliert seine dna um etwas
dinosaurier ähnliches zu produzieren nun
es ist wie jeder andere gehen
modifikation er ein spieler mit der
genetik unsere gesamte landwirtschaft
alle haustiere selbst die hühner sind ja
nicht naturbelassen
überall haben die menschen über eine
zucht auswahl gene manipuliert das wäre
nur eine weitere spielart ich sehe dass
weder negativ noch positiv
man wird das wohl auch ich wage die
voraussage dass wir in den nächsten zehn
bis 15 jahren von einer pressekonferenz
überrascht werden an der ein
wissenschaftler einen velociraptor an
einer leine herein führt der aus einem
hohen kreiert wurde
mein einwand hierzu aber ist dass wir ja
mit den vögeln bereits lebende
dinosaurier haben
das ist ja auch der grund weshalb wir
einen hohen dahingehend manipulieren
können dass es aussieht wie ein pilot
erato hühner sind bereit jetzt
dinosaurier
sie haben die gene ihre dinosaurier
vorfahren
deshalb brauchen wir das nicht zu tun
aber als paläontologe und begeistert hat
dinosaurier fan verstehe ich natürlich
warum man etwas erschaffen möchte dass
wir ein velo therapeut aussieht es wäre
wirklich cool das zu sehen und auch für
die öffentlichkeit eine tolle
gelegenheit über themen wie evolution
und genetik zu diskutieren deshalb denke
ich dass es wohl passiert wir werden sie
ich würde gerne noch einmal auf die
kritik auch zurückkommen wahl in
jurassic park ist ja schon so bereits im
roman angelegt dass das auch eine art
technik kritische stimme davor kommt das
ist eine kapitalismuskritische
geschichte auch weil menschen einen
vergnügungspark machen mit dinosauriern
man wird sehr viel geld damit verdienen
und das ganze gerät außer kontrolle zum
beispiel versuchen die dinosaurier so
herzustellen dass sie sich nicht
vermehren können das geht schief wann
fällt elektrizität aus die tiere brächen
aus und das ganze gibt einen riesen
durch ein allein an dieser menschen
sterben und so weiter denken sie auch
dass bei so einem who knows die sache
außer kontrolle geraten könnte und wenn
nein warum nicht
das ist eine wirklich interessante
fragen michael crichtons buch jurassic
park ist sehr gut und unterhaltsam wie
sie sagten wurde es 1990 veröffentlicht
in den 80er jahren machte man sich
sorgen über einen ausufernden
kapitalismus
es war die zeit von wall street
kritisch wird der renault mix in den usa
ich lehne mich weit aus dem fenster
hinaus wenn ich über politik sprechen
aber es war ein buch aus jener zeit
viele dieser themen geraten heute wieder
in den fokus der vergnügungspark mit dem
man geld machen will
alles außer kontrolle gerät das thema
der menschen die die natur manipulieren
und dem versuch sie besser zu machen die
dinge verschlimmern
das sind alles berechtigt natürlich ist
das aber kein grund gehen veränderte
nahrungsmittel zu fürchten denn all
unsere nahrungsmittel sind ja nichts
anderes
weizen mais oder reis wachsen ja nicht
wild sondern wurden ja von menschen
angebaut
im laufe der zeit weiter gezüchtet ganz
allgemein ist das also in ordnung
ich weiß aber nicht was ein humors
anrichten könnte wenn ein paar exemplare
flüchteten und sich natürlich vermehren
würden
vielleicht wäre das etwas unheimlich ich
weiß es nicht
zum schluss noch verraten sie uns noch
ihren lieblings dinosaurier ich weiß
jeder sagte rix aber für mich ist der
direkte eines der erstaunlichsten tiere
die es je gegeben hat
er war der größte fleischfresser der je
zu lang gelebt hat er war so groß wie
ein bus und biss so hart zu dass er die
knochen seiner beute dabei zu meinte
terex ist ein wunder der evolution ich
liebe ihn ja nächste woche spricht mein
kollege wolfram eilenberger mit charles
taylor dem geistigen vater des
multikulturalismus über die suche nach
der perfekten gesellschaft und jetzt
gleich nehmen wir die spur auf von elena
franz deren weltbestseller meine geniale
freundin nun auch als fernsehserie zu
entdecken ist skivergnügen eine gute
woche und bis bald
[Musik]